what are you feeling right now because
this is such an exciting time this
movies so good and the fact that is like
Saturday night in New York City at MoMA
the greatest plays possible and you know
Greta Gerwig wanted a revolution in
honor as an homage to Louisa May Alcott
and we got to come along for the ride of
our lives it was incredible it's a great
great gift and a gorgeous film and to
open Christmas Day and be about voice
and what it means to be an artist and
revolution it's really incredible
Monday morning what would it mean to be
recognized at the globe's for either of
your projects because people are talking
about you for this and they're also
talking about you for marriage story I
mean I love Greta Gerwig and Noah
Baumbach they are my family to have made
a movie with both of them in the same
year and consider them both perfect
films of course all I want is for them
to be acknowledged and more and more
people that get to see their work so
that's always delicious okay the other
thing everyone's been thinking about is
where's baby Oda and I know you went to
the basketball game and still have like
you seen baby o2 anywhere lately
I mean Timmy and I have seen I saw
something the other night but it just
keeps going then I saw him in my coffee
today I saw that on your Instagram and I
was like just everywhere now I don't
even know what's happening
I love the friendship though even in our
junket interview and then you guys went
to the basketball game like what is it
about he loves you so much they love him
so much and he's a gorgeous human and
actor and we really are a deep family
like this one here I know what a night
it's just literally like having my
family around
it's really beautiful that the
sisterhood and the bond and family bond
in this film is such a pivotal and
important moment of this story you're
pulled in so many directions in
Hollywood what a poor the people that
keep you grounded who do you depend on
for just when it's like sweatpants Laura
my children my stepchildren and my best
friends of which I include these
filmmakers and these girls and Timmy I
mean I'm just so lucky that the that's
what's gorgeous about getting to be in a
collaborative art where you go off on a
journey together and it's not always
like that but we move to Massachusetts
together for four months and you know
that's a very bonding experience unless
thing you've been doing amazing work
your entire career but what does it feel
like to be like on this 2019 like this
is some of the best work of your career
and it's all coming out like during the
same time well I'm just you know I'm in
bliss and the fact that Gretta and Noah
gave me such incredibly diverse
characters and you know we my other
family an amazing group of friends that
we make big little lies together I mean
it's just you know it's what you dream
of your whole life to get to work with
people you love so deeply I will not be
making laura dern pick her favorite
award season movie between her two
movies on ET but I'll tell you later
what mine is
okay bye marriage women
[Music]